[Music]
well welcome to a special episode of the
addie hour today i'm honored to be able
to host two scientific directors from
the national institutes of health for a
conversation we're really going to be
focusing on physical and mental wellness
and also talking about racial
disparities specifically within the
context of our scientific research and
in the context of our scientific
workforce also with an emphasis on our
scientific trainees so i'm honored to
welcome two guests today the first of
which is dr amy newman dr newman is the
scientific director at the national
institute on drug abuse a role that she
has served in since 2020 and prior to
that she was actually the acting
scientific director for two years
dr newman received her undergraduate
degree in chemistry at mary washington
college and also went on after that to a
phd in medicinal chemistry from the
medical college of virginia and virginia
commonwealth university then went on to
postdoctoral training at niddk
dr newman is someone who has been
prolific in the field and has
contributed immensely to our knowledge
in this area as it was stated during the
nih press release when she took this
position she has performed work focusing
on the design synthesis and evaluation
of central nervous system acting agents
as potential therapeutics for substance
use disorders she has published over 300
articles is also an inventor on multiple
nih patents
and one of the things i really
appreciate about dr newman in addition
to our outstanding science is her
emphasis on training and mentorship so
in 2019 she received the chris shine
mentoring award from the office of the
director of the nih and in 2018 was
recognized as a remarkable woman in
medicinal chemistry from the american
chemical society so someone who has had
a lot of impact both scientifically and
in terms of people's uh training and
development over the years so i'm
honored to be able to welcome dr newman
to the addie hour podcast
thank you so much me oh thanks so much
for being here
our second guest which i'm pleased to
introduce is dr luigi furuchi who is the
scientific director at the national
institute on aging
uh dr ferrucci is a geriatrician and an
epidemiologist who conducts research on
the causal pathways leading to
progressive physical and kind of decline
in older persons
he
received a lot of his training at
florence at the university
university of florence in italy where he
also received his phd and has board
certification in geriatrics he served on
the faculty at that university for quite
a while an associate professor of
biology human physiology and statistics
at the university of florence and also
between 1985 and 2002 was the chief of
geriatric rehabilitation at the
department of geriatric medicine and
director of the laboratory of clinical
epidemiology at the italian national
institute of aging
so luigi is someone who has performed
research across
several different continents there's a
lot of work
both in the u.s and in europe a lot of
longitudinal studies specifically
looking at risk factors for mobility uh
disability in older persons in september
of 2002 he became the chief of the
longitudinal studies section at the
national institute on aging and the
director of the baltimore longitudinal
study on aging and then in 2001 became
the scientific director at nia so
someone who has a long-standing history
in the field has made several
contributions and has also served in
several different leadership roles so
again honored to be able to welcome dr
luigi furuchi to the addie hour podcast
as well
thank you very much i'm looking forward
to this conversation yes i am as well
and i feel like this is a a two-for-one
deal i know the two of you interact
quite a bit and i'm honored to be able
to host both of you simultaneously and
to hear some complimentary perspectives
um that you all have in your roles of
scientific directors and in your roles
in mentoring and in leadership as well
so as our listeners know i always like
to start out just checking in with our
guests to see how they're doing and
before we get there though i did want to
put this in context a little bit as well
because i think there are some things
that scientists that we all share in
common
especially with everything that's gone
on over the last 18 months i think a lot
of us as scientists have become de facto
experts for our friends and and our
colleagues and families whether we feel
like we fit that role as well or not um
but just with you know the way that
science has been talked about publicly
recently obviously with covet and also
with the last election i feel like
science has been elevated in the
conversation some for good some for not
so good but it's given us an opportunity
in a lot of ways as well
but i know for me personally and others
i've talked to we sometimes become you
know de facto infectious disease experts
or vaccine experts or immunologists or
epidemiologists of course luigi in your
case that is appropriate
in terms of the epidemiology
but i did want to also just talk about
the ways that we are also all going
through this as well just like everybody
else and not always an easy journey
so if we could just start you know
talking a little bit about how you've
personally experienced the last 18
months and how that has also played out
in your professional role as a scientist
working with scientific trainees um so
dr newman if we could start with you
thank you me uh it has been a roller
coaster and i think that i'm probably
have many people on that roller coaster
with me
as you noted i became the actual
scientific director just in november i
was the acting scientific director
before that so within this 18 months i
was also applying for the job that i was
in and hoped to remain in
experiencing that the many changes that
we had to quickly make to have people
first of all work from home and figure
out how to do that and then slowly get
back but even now uh being distanced and
masked and and so forth it has been
quite an adjustment and i think that
where i get the most thrill is that
we're we're doing it and you know
despite the fact that it's not been easy
and there's certainly been trauma along
the way we have figured it out for the
most part at just about every level not
to say that we don't want to get back we
all want to get back we want to be
together and and do the work that we we
do best and that we love most but i
think that i'm i'm really
delighted with the resilience that i've
seen and for the most part the
flexibility that we've had to have at
every level in order to kind of keep on
doing what we're doing because we can't
stop we're serious and not only do we
love it but i think you know i really
think that work that we do is so
important to continue to do in the best
way that we can
yeah very well said there's a lot of
hope there as well i like that the the
full picture that you gave not that it's
been easy or there haven't been
challenges along the way but that things
are still moving forward i think that's
really important and i appreciate you
bringing that bringing that out as well
what about you
i i you know certainly i agree with most
of what amy said you know it's been
challenging
i think the most challenging part to me
uh has been
you know losing
that direct connection that unspoken
language that connect people and
scientists
and you know being able and make an
effort to continuously connect with them
so that
you become the thread
that reinforce you know the spirit of a
team
and and i have to say that analogously
what what any say i'm amazed how people
responded to this child how you know the
scientific product of tv did not
went down you know people found any
possible way to maintain
attention and focus on their work you
know they could not collect data they
use the data they had to analyze them
and writing their paper they
kept having you know their lab the
meeting you know virtually i i have to
say that that you know people have been
marvelous you know to me how they of
course
there's been weaknesses
some of our trainees
and not only the trainees i've been
really subject to
great stress and and you know
uh for me it's been
a
you know an attempt to support them in
many different ways
and at the same time i was dealing with
my personal situation because my
family is in italy so we couldn't travel
so i stayed 18 months
without visiting my family and so there
was the stress of not traveling the
stress of having to you know maintain an
issue so that at the end of this period
that we will have
you know an nia and a nida that are
still alive
and can produce that important work that
they do
you know it's a mixed bag i learned a
lot i think that
if we get out from here if the grip of
cavity 19
release
will do things differently because we
have learned something from this
experience
yeah that's very well said as well
there's so many important points that
you both brought up uh just the
realities of the whole thing and i like
that you talked about the personal
aspect for you as well because you're
still leading even though you yourself
haven't seen your family um in 18 months
and then amy as you mentioned just the
resilience that's been there as well on
both sides even you know even while
there are challenges along the way
several different points i wanted to
actually follow up on but one you know
luigi you you mentioned it and hinted at
the expectation in a sense for nia and
for nida there's an expectation that the
work will continue how have you seen
that
impact
yourselves and those around you has that
been good pressure has it been
challenging pressure especially as you
said you know some have thrived under
this but some have also had challenges
with the stress um any
anything that you've noticed that's come
out with that i think globally we are
done fantastically i think that there is
uh there's been event episode of
difficulties but even those that
went under stress
adequately supported
they were able to come out
you know i've seen that
people were highly receptive
discussion to communication and so in
general
you know
certainly not everything went as perfect
as we wanted
and you know one of the things that you
said at the beginning for example is
very important
you know at some point everybody became
expert
in epidemiology of viral disease you
know everybody was a virology everybody
was trying to write on coveted 19 and
initially i was kind of upset for that
you know this is the science you can't
really improvise yourself to be but then
i realized that
to some extent this was a coping
strategy
you know instead of being only the
receiver of the negative effect of
covid19
being a protagonist and contribute in
some way or another with your scientific
expertise the solution of the problem
and so i realized that
you know all these
you know trying to elaborate the new
ideas especially in the field of aging
where you know recovery 19 is really
being hit in the weaker and you know all
the people are certainly one of the
biggest components of our population was
really
extraordinary positive so in the end i
think that
my view is very positive i think as i
said will come out from this a little
bit better than we were before that
that's what i think it is
i think from our side there's two groups
that that really
suffered a lot
and one were those who are in uh who
have small children at home or
school-aged children at home and this
does hit not only our post-docs and
junior faculty but also many of our
administrators who we completely depend
on to keep us going forward and having
to figure out how to
teach your children from home and get
your kindergarten on a laptop and and
those kinds of things i think was
extremely
stressful for that group and i think
some of them really
felt like they were
not able to move forward in the job that
they wanted to do because they have a
whole new job that was extremely new to
them and not something they were
necessarily good at and they had to do
it there was no other no other choice i
think that was really tough the other
thing the other
group
our clinical researchers and you know we
we work with substance use some
substance use disorders and that has
skyrocketed during covet i mean that is
just a tremendous
number of overdose deaths much higher
than it has been in several years and
can't even do our patient studies we
can't do our clinical work right now to
the degree that we had before we've just
started to open up some clinical studies
this summer but it's at a much slower
capacity and so i think our clinical
researchers feel frustrated because this
is what they do and that's the
population that they want to serve it's
really suffered and and they're kind of
if anything slow but almost stopped in
their traps for the last 18 months
what have been some of the ways that you
all have tried to address that in the
meantime
just being in that place of it sounds
like a mixture of one feeling stuck and
two
not being able to help the people that
you feel like you're called to serve as
well so how how do you address that
well i i think that uh
you know the most difficult part is that
when you are in the building when you
meet people in the corridor when you
get coffee with them you know when you
have all these informal
meeting with them that they're not
predisposed
you keep track of what is happening
you know you're feeling the sense of
whether there is something wrong that's
going on in the people you know the
gesture their posture the way they you
know say hello to you for the moment
and i i felt that i i was completely
missing that
you know for example like this is a
stupid episode but
i'll tell you how much this was
important
you know during christmas time last year
i had so much longing for the people
that work in my office of the scientific
director
that i visited each one of them now i
went to their home
i saw them for one minute but we were
face to face and i got i don't think
they got a lot from me but i did i did
like i felt that that human connection
water constitute and what i'm afraid is
that why our productivity will be high
re-establish those uh
informal and and uh you know hard
connection
it's not going to be automatic we will
need to work hard to do that and and i
intend to do it you know by having
meeting with people creating an informal
informal way of
you know
creating groups
that even even not based on the
scientific but
thursday last week
at the end of the day we went for a walk
you know masking everything was
it was incredible you know i talked to
people just for you know two months of
walking but interacting with them and
and and you know see how right and and
and inventive and creative they are i
think that gave me a lot but i think it
also they felt that you know their
scientific director their leader was
with them and i want them to feel that i
am with them
i learn from them and i feel that they
are you know in my same journey that's
great on the journey together anything
you were going to add there as well that
that's i did not do the one-on-one like
that but one thing that we did was that
we had listening sessions
but one-on-one with every single faculty
member and they had just 30 minutes but
i had two questions one is tell me about
the most one most exciting project that
you're working on or you want to work on
and then tell me the challenges that you
have to prevent you from moving forward
as quickly or as effectively as you want
to and they were and we did this with
all the faculty and then we did it in
groups with our staff scientists and
staff clinicians and we even did a group
with the postdocs and
i think that it was so super fun it was
great to see that enthusiasm despite the
situation it was very informative to
hear what the challenges were many
i knew but some of them i didn't and
also i know how many people found
certain things to be challenging and so
that gave me my you know my orders to
move forward and try to fix those things
but um especially with like my staff
scientists and staff clinicians they
said you know
i've never had a chance to talk to my
scientific director this is the first
time i've ever talked to my scientific
director they ever asked me to have a
conversation and
you know i got a lot out of that but i
think they did too
and the other thing that that i did this
summer because we could do it i have a
nice backyard we live kind of out in the
country and we lined up big picnic
tables and i invited my whole group for
outdoor lunch and they i made lunch and
they were all outside and it was so fun
i mean we hung out here for hours and it
was just a great chance to be together
and again i loved it but i think they
really loved it too and you know it's
just a one-off i wish i could do it more
often this is something that i really
like to do luigi and i both love cooking
and we love to entertain and it's
something that we've really not been
able to do like but those little tiny
gestures seem to have been useful for
all of us yeah that's great and i
appreciate you peeling back the layers
because as you were both talking about
how
you know
groups are still here people are still
moving forward that was one thing i was
just really wondering like the layers
underneath that what you had done it
sounds like it's been some new
creativity in that sense too and you
know as we were talking before we
started
the session as well you know the things
that we don't get trained on as
scientists but which i think we're all
becoming much more aware of the
importance of you know i mean just
having people over having those touch
points luigi having your your drive-bys
to just connect with people
and connect and chat with them and how
important that is for all of us in so
many ways i mean you learn
you know that but you learn more and
more
that
only a place that make people
enthusiastic and happy
becomes productive
you know you need to make them want it
to come to work you need to make them
being
you know thinking that the best thing
they can do is to interact with the
group
and if you're able to do that
that is an incredibly powerful force you
know you don't really have to teach them
how to pipe it
you need to tell them if they come here
and they pipet they will make a
discovery and they will be extremely
happy because of that discovery i think
that
that is the most important thing that we
need to do as leaders
you know and
and then they they they will
grow professionally by themselves you
know somebody told me once that
when you're trainees
you don't have to take their hands
continuously you know you are
like a flight control you know
person that uh follow them and and and
uh
they you tell them where to go but they
actually know where to go and
only until the when
there is bad weather or when they for
some reason are losing in their
direction and then you have to go there
put them in the right direction and then
allow them to fly by themselves
and i think that i find that creating a
good environment
and a safety net where they know
if they get in trouble there's somebody
there that will help them it's really
the best way to handle our trainees
yeah it sounds like it's building a
community and making sure that it's
sincere authentic and that people know
that you're there
to be supportive which is so important
and would you say those are similar
principles that you
so try to apply as well it reminded me
of a quote from your previous podcast uh
dr wrestler and jones marlin when they
said uh in quotes cohesion can buffer
trauma and i love that i wrote that down
because i thought yes you know if we
have that community where where we have
these relationships which i think are so
important and like luigi i i want people
to love their science i want them to be
able to pipette or my case i want them
to be able to run a reaction and not
blow themselves up it's really important
you know having said that what i always
say to them is you know it's as
important to to really work on your
communication skills and your
development of relationships because as
chemists we can make compounds all day
long but if i don't have neuroscientists
and behavioral pharmacologists and
computational biophysicists and all
those people to help me put help me put
those molecules into perspective and to
help me know what tools are needed and
and then give me the opportunity to say
wow we just made something that nobody
else has ever made and we just unlocked
a biological secret that would have been
continued to be elusive without poland
that's that's the thing i think is so so
so much fun about
and i hope um is the role model that we
play as scientific directors for for all
those who work with us
yeah so important so well sad just the
importance of that diverse community in
terms of our science and our teams and
things like that
of course you know that brings up a
topic that i wanted to kind of touch on
as well because clearly the scientific
diversity is so important but we've also
been just trying to walk through all the
the racial diversity issues the racial
reckoning that you know many of us are
trying to walk through and and hoping
that it's a true racial reckoning but
then also seeing you know ups and downs
along the way and all the racial
disparities i know both of your
institutes have aspects of health
disparities research as well but i'm
just curious you know as we've been
talking along the lines of the coco like
how have those
components impacted you all on a
day-to-day basis in your roles as
directors and in your interactions with
your teams
so i guess that one of the things that's
come out of it for us is
again this kind of grassroots
growing of of acknowledgement of the
importance of that and not only do we
have kind of a faculty led diversity um
committee but we have a trainee that
started and it's called the idea
committee including
equity um
and they they are they are they're
educating us so every month they send
they they send out an email where
they're they're explaining you know some
aspect of racial diversity or or
during black history month or different
things and they're educating us they're
bringing speakers into our institution
what they're doing is being part of a
solution which frankly
we need we need everyone and i think to
be part of that solution and to try to
to help us improve and really
recognize the importance of diversity in
that community and how it how it really
brings science to the very best that it
can be
that's great to hear
anything you want to add there
i think that that's the way you know
said is is absolutely in the right
direction i i
i have the feeling that
we need to attract
you know more i mean as nih as an nih
environment we have so much to offer
and so
we're not doing enough outreach
we're not showing our cards around
showing how much
being nih could be a very successful
environment
you know for everybody and you know for
underrepresented minority
disadvantage you know young training
trainees
and and so
why and and i you know i think that at
some point i did not realize that i was
part of the problem because yes i
thought you know we need to reach to
minority you know diversifying our
workforce is important
but one of many things that they needed
to do and i am glad that at some point
that this was transformed into a central
team and so
we got a lot of information and in a way
i realized much more
that this was an
incredibly important
you know part
of what nih need to transform itself and
become
you know a true scientific enterprise
and so
that time i think that many many try to
address the problem i still feel that
we don't have
enough people coming in
when we advertise for our position
so what do we need to do is to go and
stimulate
you know the
progress of young investigators that
are attracted by coming to nih and
realize that their scientific dreams
so i i i think that we're doing a little
bit of outreach
but i think we should do better you know
i thought and discussing with some of
the other scientific directors we should
create a movie about what nih does
showcase some example of high success
you know show the technology and the
good stories that uh you know i'd be
realizing and then go to the different
academic institutions but if we do not
expand that base
i don't think the solution is fighting
for the few
candidates i don't think the solution is
that the yale and nih fight to get that
candidate and offer more we need to
expand that base because the base is
there so we need to find way to realize
that and and and and i think that many
many people now are
really
uh considering that is an important part
of their our mission and so i i'm
hopeful that um you know with some up
and down as you were explaining i think
that of course the political you know
situation where we live will impact that
but
if we have enough time i think we can
make a dent on this problem
and again that makes me think about the
importance of the community aspect as
well both the community and the
communication because you're talking
about making sure that the community is
projecting and expanding but that
through the communication of those in
the community to make sure that other
communities are pulled in as well i
think that's really important um and as
a as well as what the environment is
like um and amy as you're mentioning you
know it's encouraging to hear about
the trainees stepping up and providing
those resources and all those things as
well i was gonna ask a follow-up
question there because that even in
itself can sometimes be a point of
tension as well in terms of where the
where the onus is with the trainees as
they are going through their their
training taking on extra work so how is
that whole dynamic um playing out
because we've seen it in a lot of ways
black and narrow is a good example as
well where the trains have really
stepped up and done a tremendous job but
also know that they need to balance
their time in terms of being trainees
and they also need the support of
administrators to actually uh implement
some of the changes and to be able to
incorporate so have those conversations
been part of the
part of the process it's not from your
responses i'm thinking it has been
the thing is that it's it what a
wonderful time to learn it right so when
you're in this kind of
post-baccalaureate or post-doctoral time
you're learning science and how to
figure out how to do research and so
forth but also
that you're not just a scientist as
luigi said in the beginning
if we're just scientists we're not doing
our job we really need to learn to to do
these other things and find out what
we're good at not all of us are good at
all things that's why the diversity
comes into being so important and so yes
i think some of our trainees end up
spending a lot of time on the on these
committee responsibilities and not so
much time in the laboratory and then
sometimes we have to reel them back in a
little bit but on the other hand if
that's what they really love and that's
how they really contribute then i think
that that's that's great i mean one
thing i was going to go back to with
regard to the community and not the
scientific community but in baltimore
for example
i wonder why weird the national
institute on drug abuse is in baltimore
and it's largely because baltimore had
the drug abuse problem bethesda didn't
baltimore has had an opioid crisis for a
lot longer than the rest of the country
has and yet
we still have trouble recruiting clients
subjects into our our studies and i
think in part there is this they don't
know that we exist that we're there um
in part there is a distrust for
government experimental
work and we have to somehow figure it
out and i don't have the answers for all
this this is really where i'm trying to
find better ways to do things and trying
to encourage
our trainees and others faculty members
to to try to break down some of those
barriers because we are not going to
address the health disparities
particular substance use disorder if we
can't get subjects into our clinical
trials and our studies and understand
what works and what doesn't and that's a
big challenge that we are really
not doing well and i think that that's
one of our big challenges going forward
yeah that seems like has so many uh
ramifications as well as you've talked
about just from the research itself and
the community and impact um i know i
mean within and i'm going to remember
not remember exactly the name of it but
i know there is a big push to make sure
that there is more diversity in terms of
geos studies so some of the local
baltimore groups have gotten involved in
that with the african ancestry uh
recruitment i know i think half jazeera
and yasmin her both on that
advisory board i'm forgetting the name
of the principal investigators there but
some i know they're working with local
church leaders and things like that are
there conversations about trying to do
similar types of things like that within
ni nia or at nida or it's curious you
know i know we're outside of the
training realm a little bit but that has
such an
important impact on society and what the
trainees are walking into i'm just
curious to hear how those conversations
everything is connected you know i think
that one of the things that is happening
is nia that is now
you know leading the
research on alzheimer's disease and
related dementia has just created
you know a new
uh initiative which is called card the
center for alzheimer's is in a very
dementia and
we will have a new building
in in bethesda that is currently you
know
i wouldn't say
half finished you know we can see
already
but one of the things that we want to do
is exactly what you said you know
doing research on neurodegenerative
disease they span across multiple
populations so we can leverage on the
fact that there are multiple positions
they look at the differences
and and and the similarity and
connecting with the epidemiology i think
that the genetic assume you know much
more sense and i'm much more informative
when it's diversified but one thing i
want to say that is connected to what
amy said
he and that really is strong i struggle
with
is that
you know the washington baltimore area
is so filled with research institution
that people are kind of tired in
participating
because we don't give them back enough
we need to find ways
to give back to the community when we
involve them we need to find way that
people feel more involved people feel
that
you know they're part of a project
they're not just you know the
uh our you know animal model that we're
using
for our studies and and
i've been struggling into finding ways
because the you know even some of the
ethical constraints we live in
do not allow for example to provide them
care
and so but i think we need to bend these
boundaries we need to find ways so that
research should become part of the
community and it's not using the
community to generate papers if we do
that i think that the involvement of
people will be much much higher oh
that's so important and it sounds like
you're hinting at some of the the policy
pieces around that as well but do you
think it's do you think there's also a
communication aspect of it um or is it
is it one of the other both in partial
discussion
that i think that
you know
when people come to the baltimore
longitudinal study of aging and we ask
them when they leave after two three day
visit
to write down you know
the impression you know one of the
things they want to know is what do you
do with the data
and so they want newsletter they want to
be informed they want to know you know
what their contribution and their
generosity resulting to and we try to do
something that
you know maybe is not is not strong you
know
i know i keep saying the same thing but
again it sounds like community
and the community that extends outside
of the research but is involved in the
community at large and that we're all
working in the same
goals together as a community whether
we're participants or researchers so i'm
trying to keep saying it but it keeps
coming up
it's the answer i think that that's a
brilliant idea luigi and how to amplify
what we're giving back to them and how
recognize that they're getting something
out of it too is that's a really big
challenge we have a clinic that that we
provide treatment methodon and
buprenorphine for um people who are
addicted to opioids but it's small and i
think we could expand that and but then
it goes into this like are we using nih
research dollars for treatment and so
again there's these these back and forth
it's it's uh i don't know if there's a
clean answer but there's got to be a
better answer than what we have right
now
and it seems so important that i mean in
some ways the solution isn't there but
it's also encouraging to hear that
that's a point that you're both
wrestling with and thinking about and
trying to improve you know one thing
that we are really in trying to increase
is even like getting out into the high
schools and going to the science fairs
and being judges and being involved and
maybe again if we can get the kids
involved and then they go home and they
talk to their parents or their family
members or their church members and and
it kind of again this
i'm sounding like i'm being redundant
but this kind of grassroots way but
that you know trickle down just hasn't
done it and i think that maybe that's
another possibility yeah yeah so really
intentional in that sense as well yeah
yeah like for the we we collect money
and we make little we give money awards
for these that come from us for for
these baltimore science fairs just no
it's not a lot but it's a little bit and
they not only do they win but they get a
little money and it's kind of exciting
and
i mean those are small things i think
that there can be much bigger ideas
coming forward
yeah that's so so important in a lot of
ways
i also want to loop back and tie in what
maybe one of the points that you made
earlier too about the trainees and
everything they're doing to really make
large impact and the balance with the
science because i feel like in a lot of
ways at least for me personally i feel
like the groups that are coming up are
doing a much better job of that um than
i did even you know when i was in that
position um you know some of these you
know more public-facing things i didn't
start so i was well into my career it
kind of settled life like that passion
is there and it's important and they're
you know running with it in a lot of
ways they're exemplary and things that
you know we can all learn from that then
you also talked about kind of the
tension between
the research and the outreach work and
so how are you all
um
encouraging that or modeling that and
then also you know similarly in your
roles as well are the ways that you also
try and balance that in your own lives
and how how does that impact kind of
this ongoing conversation and tension
between
different passions and where to pursue
them and how to balance that so any
insights that you all have that you've
shared with training
i want to say you know what to say is
true and we we do titanic effort i you
know i know that you know
there's no one single weekend that i
don't try to work and
to you know accomplish everything that
needs to be done
but uh you know
to put a a
difficult note i think that uh
you know spending our day from eight
o'clock to seven o'clock in the evening
in front of
skype or zoom
doesn't make our life easier you know i
think that
i feel like at the end of the day i'm
completely exhausted
so
why doing the same thing that i was
doing before copy 19
uh required
double of the effort you know i think
that's important to understand this and
as we do it that we are
let's say you know the
stronger link you know we need to be the
one that never cracked
because you know people should see us as
an anchor
or to you know that they cannot be
attached to
you know our scientists our staff
scientists our trainees
are experiencing the same problem you
know the same kind
of exhaustion
and so
you know you go back to the idea that
mutual support
you know
i think that and you're right when you
say that this generation
are especially in the trainee people
that
are more likely to help each other some
of them get to enter crisis the other
come in
and try to be a support network
this is certainly happening in many of
our labs you know even when there is a
real crisis you can see that
you know people get together if not
physically at least virtually and and
and create the support to each other and
we need to encourage that you know for
example in my lab
is one of my staff scientists that
organize
you know happy hours every friday
afternoon and and
and you know people come and go and
they're there and that's an opportunity
for them to connect and also to hear
what's happening to others you know i
say before
my fear is that something is happening
that
will lead to something bad and i don't
perceive that because i'm not there
because
you know you have one-on-one
conversation
the buzz
that is in the building that you can
hear without paying attention is no
longer there and that is the part that
we're missing that is extremely
dangerous
i think that
i have a very strong self-preservation
streak
so i know that i cannot work
24 7. and i said i hate that term one of
the things that i do every week is i
write a little message to my whole
intramural program it's just like from
my heart to their ears
or not they can delete it or they can
read it but it's always something
personal and one of my messages some
months back was 24 7. get rid of that
term nobody really works 24 7 and no one
should even say that they work 24 7. and
i think at the end i said something like
the only thing you really can do
24 7 is breathe and i suspect that
yes definitely well said
yeah
so important i have to model that i mean
i think that it's easy to to just always
work and always you know pedal as fast
as you can and
i do think that
in my messages and just in my life i do
try to
exemplify that i love my work and i love
the work that we do and the
collaborations we have and so forth but
you know what i also made a dozen
containers of pesto this weekend because
i harvested a lot of my basil or you
know
i i i i'm having 12 people for crabs
tonight because my son just flew in from
washoe he's a resident and neurology
resident he just flew in this afternoon
and we're having all of his friends
that we have to show that we also are
human beings and that you have to be
able to take care of yourself because if
your well is dry you don't want anything
to give and and i don't think that
that's good for anybody
that's really important and i'm glad
you're
being so vocal about that a lot of ways
too do you feel like that is
getting incorporated into the culture
because i would say you know if i ask
many of the trainees that i work with
they would say that's not always their
impression their impression is they have
to stay on the grind
this is their formative years if they
take a step back or take a time to
breathe and pause someone else will
continue that work and have the position
they were looking for so how
is that getting incorporated in the
culture or do you think this is a unique
perspective that you're you're uh
about that knee is when i said i went we
took a vacation this summer and one of
my messages i was going on vacay and i
had so many people send me a message and
say thank you
no i feel like i
i can join
or i can tell people i'm going on
vacation because we're so in a
leadership position i think a lot of
times we're so afraid to admit that
we're going on vacation oh wow we're not
watching the you know the place every
every moment and i think that it's uh
that but you know yeah
people need to keep on working hard and
want to work i actually you know the
balance between life and work it's
really important and
of course so we need to but i also think
that uh
everybody is different
i mean i don't think that there is one
measure for everybody i think for some
of the
trainees for example you know working
really really hard give them the sense
that they're not losing the opportunity
of their career some are more relaxed
and they accept the idea that
you know maybe that this is happening to
them but
you know i always reinforce the idea
that
you know nih has been fantastic in this
crisis we have been given to people we
they i don't know who we think we're in
incredible flexibility
now you have to deal with the children
deal with the children you don't have to
have to work because we understand that
the value of maintaining the health of
our society
you know
we alternate people so we don't have you
know
too much
concentration of people in the building
the reason there has been incredible
support
i have to tell you that this amount of
flexibility
to some extent the surprise of me
you know that that this was possible
it was really a discovery and i think
that has been a really fantastic choice
to do that because
that will allow people to relax enough
in the moment of crisis but as i said
some people when i tell them to relax
they just look at me like i'm crazy
because they don't want to relax they're
losing ground so they want to work
night and day and if they want to
i can't really teach them what they are
they know who they are and so i think
that they need to support them for what
they want to do
that's really important really well said
i love hearing about that flexibility as
well because i mean it ties back to the
point that you both made at the
beginning as well that things really
seem to be continuing in terms of the
work and the productivity and that just
shows me the flexibility even though
some might say that's detrimental but
the way that you build respondents has
not been detrimental at all as things
have continued as people have been able
to continue to move forward
but to your point luigi as well just the
the individuality
that's there and people have to know
themselves and what works for them but i
mean it still sounds like in some ways
you're also empowering people by just
saying that you are going on vacation
and people are having the freedom
to incorporate that as well so it seems
like on all layers you know you're
showing that but then also people are
still learning from it as well
but i think i think it's such an
important point to know that it's an
individually based piece i always you
know with new trainees that come in i
always tell them how i've had trainees
that i've had to tell to spend more time
in the lab because they weren't putting
the effort in but i've also had
trainings i've had to tell to spend less
time in the lab because they were
spending so much time overthinking
basically running themselves
into a wall spraying themselves in that
when they took a pause they were like oh
i can actually think more clearly and
use my time more efficiently and they
actually got more productive
spending less time that's obviously
dangerous to share because sometimes you
know people could be tempted to take
that to extremes but i think it's it's
important to know that that balancing
act is there and people need to know
where they need to take their breaks and
where they need to continue to move
forward
by the way i mean during the weekend i
made tomato
sauce and and peach jam so
i can't wait to come to your house and
eat some of it luigi you can try them
yes there's definitely a food vibe going
on here as well you both are going to
have to be careful because you're going
to have a lot of requests after this
episode once people hear that
one of the things that luigi did before
the pandemic and i'm sure he'll do it
again because we're really limited with
what we can do with awards so like
poster awards and things like that you
know they get a little paper plate paper
plaque and uh luigi has has the winners
to his house for dinner i mean that's a
really big set of i love that and i
think that oh you'll be able to do that
too yeah it's it's pretty cool
that sounds like a great incentive to me
trust me if you've ever had well come
and visit and you know some italian food
you will be happy i promise you
i'm excited already
well i know i know that our time has
gone very quickly here which doesn't
surprise me and perhaps we'll have to do
this again in the future as well um but
just to tie in and i'm just curious to
hear from both of you what you're
um
what you're hopeful for in the months
ahead i mean you've both talked about
some of the resilience and the ways that
we've been created but what are you what
are you hoping for as scientific
directors and for your uh your
institutes and your trainees as we move
forward
luigi we'll start with you this time i
know that's not one question
well uh
you know as i said
i hope that
the grief of governmenting will be
released soon
and then we can
take back our journey with the new
awareness
of what this pandemic had taught us
and
how important is to remain connected as
a community
and how as you said before
maintaining flexibility
will not put us now but actually support
us
as a community and make us more
productive i think that
my hope that will come out from this
fast enough
so that we can fully recover i have a
little bit of fear too
and the fear is that if this thing goes
on for a long time
that
you know unprocessed language
that connection that we had as
more new people come in
will be lost
and will be very very difficult to
recreate it will be a major effort
to recreate that uh
language that is informal and that is
not verbal and and
i can certainly i will certainly try to
you know push that
uh project
that in the back of my mind
that's what i'm afraid of although
in general i'm very awful for a positive
you know exit from this all right i
appreciate it
and i want to embrace people i want
that that's what i want i want the world
of friendship
yes definitely definitely hoping and
looking forward to that as well amy what
about you
i mean i think that for me the thing
that i'm most excited about is that
during this time period as i've just
become the sd and under the
under the whole pandemic thing we've
been working pretty hard behind the
scenes to make some pretty big changes
and in the way that we do business at at
nida and i am so excited to see this pan
out and i i feel like we've got the next
year or two there's a lot of new things
that we're bringing in and really i hope
pushing the translation that i've always
wanted to have happen as a chemist i'm
i'm really
sure that i've cured enough rats of
cocaine abuse i'd really like to get
that beyond rats
we've got we're putting some things in
place that i think are going to be
fantastic we've got some new recruits
that are not only fantastic themselves
but very committed to diversity i think
are going to really bring in some new
ideas for outreach and i'm just
can't wait for that to happen but i
recognize that it's not going to happen
right away so i guess but what i'm
hopeful for is that the lessons that
we've learned and the resilience that
we've demonstrated in the last 18 months
will continue to follow us as we deal
with whatever this coronavirus is going
to deal to us and
oh yeah i'm i'm an optimist we're going
to get through this and we're going to
be better for it it's just um we just
have to hang in there
so well said well i'm excited to hear
about the new initiatives as well and
all that's been brewing that you all
been working on so hard um and i also
appreciate you know i know just the
sense between you and luigi just the
camaraderie amongst the institutes and
the similar aligning and parallel goals
in a lot of ways so it's encouraging for
me to hear just the way that things have
continued to move forward i'm definitely
interested in doing an extended
conversation at some point as well and
even coming back to some of these ideas
in the future so hopefully at some point
in person even though we've all been
virtual up to this point but definitely
appreciate it
go ahead it's good
anytime
excellent
well it's been great meeting both of you
officially i know we've corresponded
beforehand and i appreciate again just
your level of candor uh that you shared
on this adi hour podcast i know it's
gonna be a unique uh setup in a lot of
ways but something i think will really
be important as we've peeled back the
layers so thank you again to dr amy
newman dr luigi furuchi for being
willing to come and to join on this
addie hour podcast and so all our
listeners have some exciting episodes
coming up in the future as well so
definitely stay tuned
[Music]
you